Hey team it’s Charlie, I hope you all had
a chance to watch the SHIELD Premiere.
I think it’s on ABCs website now, or should
be shortly.
People in the UK, Channel 4 hasn’t officially
announced a premiere date for you guys yet
other than October.
That’s kind of vague, but I think you were
about four weeks behind during season 1.
So tentatively plan for October 14th.
That’s when Episode 4 drops in the United
States.
I’d recommend for anyone who feels like
they can’t wait, just try to find a way
to watch the episodes on ABC dot com.
This video is going to be a Q&A just following
up on the big big stuff from the episode,
so careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Question 1 - It’s A Bit Windy asks do you
think Simmons will only be a hallucination
or will she come back as a main cast member?
Yes, she’s definitely coming back for real,
not just as a hallucination.
The third episode is kind of a sequel to SEEDS
from last year.
It features the kid that turned into Blizzard.
His name in the comics is Donnie Gill.
Since that was a very FitzSimmons centric
episode, I’m guessing we’ll find out what
she’s been up to.
I’m actually not sure what she’s been
doing since the finale last season, but she’s
still very much a part of the show.
The actress who plays her is still a main
cast member.
So she’ll be featured in most of the episodes.
As for future hallucinations, they’ll have
to address them at some point.
So I expect them to continue off and on until
Fitz gets his own big episode where they really
address it.
At some point, someone on the team is going
to have to call him on it.
I’m really hoping that Kraken offers to
fix his brain in exchange for Fitz’s help.
I’d really like to see him do something
totally crazy to try and restore himself.
Question 2 - Low Buffalo asks I just watched
Winter Soldier and wondered why none of the
Avengers helped out?
I feel like everyone had this same question,
they will address it directly in Age of Ultron
in the spring.
The script addresses why they were too busy
to help in Winter Soldier.
From a practical standpoint they weren’t
going to pay to put all those actors in Winter
Soldier.
It’s Chris Evans’ movie and having them
there would have turned it into an Avengers
Movie, not a Captain America movie.
I think it’s implied that Captain America
maintains loose contact with the Earth-Based
Avengers.
Like he watches the news and saw what was
going on with the Mandarin in Iron Man 3.
Kevin Fiege also addressed why SHIELD didn’t
help out during that movie by saying they
were in the middle of this big HYDRA takeover.
So the people in charge who were responsible
for sending aide to Tony Stark were HYDRA
agents or too busy being sent on wild goose
chases by HYDRA agents.
A lot of SHIELD’s honest agents were sent
on wild goose chases all over the world to
misdirect them from what was going on at SHIELD
headquarters.
It’s a little confusing, but each movie
will explain why big characters aren’t around.
Question 3 - Nathan Zimmerman asks Do you
think Lucy Lawless’ Character is Dead?
Lucy Lawless did an interview recently where
she said “anything could happen”, what
I think that means is that either they have
a plan for her and they’re just saving it
for a big reveal or inside the writer’s
room.
They just left it open ended so that they
could turn it into something later if they
wanted.
It’s pretty common for tv shows to do something
big with a character with only part of a plan.
Especially if it’s a guest character.
The worst thing they could do is kill her
and publicly tell everyone that she’s not
coming back.
They’re just leaving things open so that
they can do whatever they want with the character
later.
What I’d like to see is either a modified
Carol Danvers arc, where she gets infused
with some kind of cosmic power or they do
something more practical, like give her some
cybernetic parts and make her super pissed
off.
I want more female super heroes with powers
on the show.
Is what I’m saying.
SHIELD is one of the few shows on television
with a relatively equal ratio of male to female
badasses.
Something I think it’s doing right.
Some of you have suggested in the comments
that the mystery alien code isn’t just Kree,
it’s like a universal language that transcends
all the Marvel Alien races.
Which would arguably make it even more important
than a Kree reveal.
That opens the door for cosmic powers and
even though I think Guardians has the first
crack at cosmic characters, I think Marvel
will use SHIELD to lay some of the groundwork
for that.
Clark Gregg said many times that Kevin Fiege
and Joss Whedon called his character, Agent
Coulson, the glue that holds the Avengers
together.
It’s possible Marvel will use this cosmic
code as the glue to bind all of the Marvel
Universe shows and Movies, including the Guardians
and all the space based characters like Thanos
and the Infinity Gems.
Question 4 - khatchat ryan asks how do you
think Kraken kept himself from aging?
I’d guess something related to the super
soldier serum or some derrivative.
There are still a few technologies that Marvel
hasn’t unveiled in the movies and tv shows
yet.
Centipede and the HYDRA tech from last year
was just the beginning.
I’d guess that it’s going to be related
to that.
Clearly he’s been keeping himself near the
age of when we saw him in the 1940s.
At that time, the only known causes for that
type of thing were the super soldier serum
and the tesseract.
The reason the Winter
Soldier is still young is because of experiments
the Red Skull did on him while he was his
captive during the first movie.
That happened before Captain America rescued
him and before he fell off the train.
He wasn’t frozen in ice or anything.
The serum they gave him is also probably what
Kraken took.
They wouldn’t do something big like that
on TV if they weren’t going to explain it.
So eventually just plan for Kraken himself
to explain why he’s still young.
Question 5 - Rick T says It seemed like the
HYDRA person in the Agent Carter scene was
addressed as Heir Heinrich, could that be
Baron Zemo keeping himself young and could
he be Skye’s Father?
I rewatched that scene a few times and it
sounds like Heir Reinhardt.
That person is Kraken on the show, Daniel
Whitehall.
As for Skye’s father, he could be Baron
Zemo.
But what I’m hoping is they save that character
for the Agent Carter Show.
Baron Zemo is one of the few major HYDRA characters
that they haven’t used in the movies or
tv shows yet.
And Agent Carter will need
a big villain.
What I think is going on with Skye’s father
is that he’s tied up in the HYDRA plot,
whether he’s connected to Red Skull or Kraken
or he’s a neutral third party.
He was calmly sitting in blood in the finale.
Look at his hand here.
He seems like he’s just chilling out.
That isn’t something a nice person does.
It makes me feel like Skye isn’t part Kree
or anything, but she is someone genetically
altered as a result of all the HYDRA testing,
the super soldier serum and the tesseract
energy.
Question 6 - wrayzor asks do you think we’ll
see more Deathlok this season?
I don’t expect to see him.
The actor who plays Deathlok, J August Richards,
was cast on a new network show called The
Lottery.
He might get a small cameo, but it seems like
he’s mostly going to be busy making this
new show.
Question 7 - atalia asks do you think the
0 8 4 device is an infinity stone?
No, but I do think it’s connected to the
infinity quest.
When I say that, I mean that it’s a link
between Thanos, the gems, the cosmic code
and all the earth based Marvel stories.
It’s just a way for the writers to start
connecting those things.
Laying groundwork for a future crossover in
the movies
and
on tv.
Question 8 - J Moe asks BJ Britt only appeared
in the press for the first couple of episodes,
do you think they might kill him off?
BJ Britt for those that don’t know is the
actor who plays Tripp.
He was spotted on the set of Avengers 2 this
year, so he’s going to be one of the crossover
characters, so he’s not getting killed off.
I think that he’s probably going to wherever
Simmons is and we’ll just see him again
when the story brings her back for real.
Not just as a hallucination.
Question 9 - anaya asks do you think Skye
heard Ward when he mentioned her father?
How do you think that’s going to play out?
No I don’t think he heard her, but I do
think he’ll tease her with it in a future
episode.
They cast Kyle Machlaclan as her father, so
they have to introduce him at some point.
I do wonder if Ward will tease her father
before the show reveals him.
He’ll probably try and use the information
about her father to keep her close.
Clearly he still has feelings for her but
he does seem like he’s playing both sides
of the fence.
Question 10 - Charmed for life karen asks
what do you think May meant when she said
she was the boss of Coulson and what do you
think her story arc will be this season?
Last season it was revealed she had been spying
on coulson for Nick Fury ever since Coulson
was brought back from the dead.
So when she says boss I think she’s implying
that Nick Fury is unofficially still the boss
and she’s his number 1 when it comes to
coulson.
At the same time, I also think it was them
being informal with each other.
Question 11 - Luna Rogers asks who’s your
favorite SHIELD character?
Right now my favorite returning SHIELD person
is probably Skye, which is a total 180 from
last season, I didn’t like her character
that much till the last couple of episodes.
It feels like she’s the most self-aware
some-nonesense character.
There’s this big outcry because of True
Detective Season 2 was supposed to feature
two female protagonists and everyone was getting
excited but they it turned out to be Colin
Farrell and Vince Vaughn.
Like two badasses that would also be kind
of funny and dark at the same time.
And I think Hollywood needs more female characters
like that.
Right now Skye is one of the closest templates,
a tough but funny lead female character.
As for my favorite new character, he’s not
a SHIELD agent, but I am pretty pumped up
about the new Villain Kraken.
Question 12 - Noe Gomez asks Do you think
Punisher could appear on SHIELD?
Marvel actually just got the rights back to
do Punisher from Fox, so it’s possible.
Fox was trying to turn Punisher into a TV
Series, but it never got going.
So the rights reverted back to Marvel.
I do think Marvel will introduce a new Punisher
character in another series or movie, probably
tv.
I think it will end up being one of the Netflix
series.
Because they don’t have to worry about ratings
or broadcast standards with the Netflix shows,
they can and will be way more graphic.
The people working on Daredevil right now
said it would be way more violent that the
stuff on ABC.
That kind of environment sounds way better
for punsiher than network tv.
But now that they have the rights back, Marvel
can drop references to Frank Castle wherever
they want.
In terms of punisher level voilence, that
scene at the end of season 1 where Clark Gregg
splatters Bill Paxton with the 0 8 4 gun,
that’s about as gory as they can get.
Let me know in the comments though, where
do you want to see the Punisher pop back up
and do you think the 0-8-4 obelisk is Kree
or something more important.
Couple of important reminders, starting with
my SHIELD Episode 3 video in a couple weeks,
videos will post later at night.
Like midnight 1AM pacific time, so just adjust
based on which time zone you live in.
That’s when Flash, Arrow and a bunch of
other stuff come back.
Next week will be just like this week though.
And I’ll probably do another Q&A.
So if you’re new to my channel and you like
talking about Marvel stuff be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
We’d love to have you on the team.
Oh and also, Star Wars Rebels is airing a
special episode Friday October 3rd.
So just to get everyone ready for that I’m
doing a preview video this friday.
Right now click here for my SHIELD episode
1 video and click here to learn more all about
The Vision in Avengers Age of Ultron.
Thanks for watching, let’s all high five
and meet back up tomorrow for some arrow and
flash.